[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire le 22 janvier dernier un
débat devait avoir lieu à sciences po
lille entre geoffroy le jeune directeur
de la rédaction de valeurs actuelles
et l'avocat charles consigny sur le
thème à droite touchant ou en sont les
idées plusieurs associations étudiantes
se sont indignés d'une telle tribune
pour l'extrême droite je les cite le
directeur de sciences po lille lui ne
voyait pas d'inconvénient à un tel débat
mais la présence du directeur de la
rédaction de valeurs actuelles ne lui
paraissaient pas souhaitables ce
magazine ayant été condamnées en 2015
pour provocation à la discrimination la
haine ou la violence envers les roms
la déprogrammation de geoffroy le jeune
pour des raisons de sécurité at-on
ajouté
à fait que le débat a été annulée nous
avons donc décidé de le faire ici dans
interdit d'interdire
je vous les présente tous les deux
schalk ont signé vous avez trente ans
vous êtes avocat dans le portrait que
vous avez consacré libération vraiment
votre arrivée comme chroniqueur chez
ruquier on vous disait je cite un
parisien né dans une grande famille
bourgeoise et gothique libéral et
conservateur
avant d'ajouter il représente la droite
qui s'assume la classe dominante sont
vous confirmez sauf la fin la classe
dominante sombre c'est faux le reste je
les assume parfaitement bons jo fois le
jeune vous avez 31 ans vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de valeurs
actuelles à magazine que toujours
libération j'ai pris le même arbitre
qualifie de très réactionnaire et situer
politiquement l extrême droite qui ne
vous empêche pas d'intervenir
régulièrement sur rtl et lci en
particulier alors très réactionnaire
situer politiquement à l'extrême droite
mais à l'heure actuelle mots très
réactionnaire ça me dérange pas parce
que j'ai fait dans ma génération que ça
c'est pas une insulte c'est plus ça va
plus la même connotation qu'avant et
ensuite à l'extrême droite pour le coup
c'est faux c'est vrai que moi je le jeu
libération dit ça ça ne m'étonne pas
mais en réalité s'ils lisaient valeurs
actuelles y en fait on s'adresse à
toutes les droites à toute forme de brad
ça va être un peu le sujet de notre
débat ce soir qu'elle soit très
pro-européenne centriste libéral etc ou
alors ce qu'on qualifie d'extrême droite
mais en fait c'est très éclectique
alors le débat moi je les avais intitulé
quelle valeur pour la droite parce qu'on
dirait que la droite aujourd'hui est à
est à la croisée des chemins en terme de
deux valeurs c'est pour ça qu'il me
semblait intéressant d'en discuter avec
vous d'après vos âges et vos engagements
respectifs alors le libéralisme par
exemple aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une
valeur de droite le libre la droite
doit-elle être vide wattel choisir le
libéralisme ou protectionnisme le
libéralisme à la langue et la merkel ou
bruno le maire ou le protectionnisme à
la donald trump
c'est moi qui commence et moi c'est une
question qui me qui me taraude beaucoup
depuis depuis quelques années parce que
je vois bien que c'est en train de
changer
et en réalité j'ai envie de vous dire si
c'est par pur calcul stratégique
la droite devrait choisir le
protectionnisme c'est dire qu'en fait on
voit que partout dans le monde ce sont
des protectionnistes qui gagne ou alors
que des gens plutôt libéraux se met au
protectionnisme pour gagner c'est
l'exemple récent de boris johnson donc
stratégiquement il ya évidemment un
créneau protectionnistes en france qui
pour l'instant est assumé un tout petit
peu par jean luc mélenchon et beaucoup
par marine le pen
la droite s'est fait bouffer par le
front national on l'a vu encore
récemment aux européennes donc je me
disent ils doivent réinventer quelque
chose surtout dans une opposition au
maquereau nice mais qui pour le coup lui
il n'y a pas du tout protectionnistes
stratégiquement il devrait aller vers
vers ce chemin là et ensuite sur la
question du libéralisme si vous voulez
ce qui me gêne c'est que je n'arrive pas
à être pour la dépense publique telle
qu'elle est conçue en france je n'arrive
pas à être pour les excès évidemment du
libéralisme la viande qui traverse le
monde de ce genre de délire qui
évidemment me hérisse et donc je pense
qu'il faudrait articulé quelque chose en
fait finalement un peu à l anglaise
façon le boris johnson d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire protectionnistes avec de la
liberté pour les entreprises ça n'existe
pas encore aujourd'hui je crois en
france en tout cas sur le l'offre
politique charles consignes et je ne
sais pas s'il faut tellement choisir je
pense que le protectionnisme il a montré
ses limites tout au long de l'histoire
il a en général était plutôt
contreproductif pour les pays qui l'ont
mis en place il a plutôt dérégler les
économies il a entraîné des mesures de
rétorsion des pays contre lesquels on
engageait ses mesures protectionnistes
puisque concrètement ça consiste à
freiner les exportations et les
importations en particulier en ce moment
dans la guerre commerciale et
l'implantation donald trump et des
chinois et comme vous dites ça se
transforme en guerre commerciale et
et celui qui est le plus malin n'est pas
toujours celui qu'on croit je ne suis
pas sûr que donald trump récoltera
forcément les fruits de la guerre
commerciale qu'il mène avec la chine
peut-être qu'au contraire l'europe se
retourner contre lui et avec l'europe et
par ailleurs je crois que c'est un non
sens sur le plan économique puisque ça
contribue à ralentir les échanges et
donc en fait à ralentir l'activité
économique je pense que personne de
raisonnable ne peut dire qu'en france on
souffre d'un excès de libéralisme c'est
pas vrai on est un peu des pays les plus
taxés du monde on est un des pays les
plus réguliers du monde
on est un pays où l'état prend une place
invraisemblable on est à des pays où le
coût du travail est le plus élevé dans
le monde
ça c'est quand même un de nos premiers
problèmes et à mon sens tout ce qu'on
doit faire c'est essayer un peu plus
libéraux le problème c'est que le
libéralisme ne paye pas du tout
politiquement on a vu le score qu'avait
fait alain madelin à l'élection
présidentielle et d'une façon générale
les candidats de droite même s'ils
portent des programmes
libero n'insiste pas tellement sur cet
aspect des choses néanmoins si on doit
en être à parler de l'avenir de la
droite et de ce que la droite pourrait
faire moi j'observe quand même que
françois fillon en 2017 avec un
programme qui était un programme libéral
et qui était surtout geoffrey lejeune en
a parlé un programme de réduction des
dépenses publiques ce qui ça je crois
est un souci majeur chez les français
qui voit bien qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation de gabegie il a réussi le
débat mais au général tous les
gouvernements successifs ont réduit les
services publics depuis au moins jacques
chirac
je ne sais pas s'ils réduisent d'abord
les services publics je ne l'espère pas
et ensuite on peut se concentrer sur les
services publics utiles même augmenter
les dépenses publiques dans certains
services publics je pense par exemple à
la santé et les réduire dans d'autres
aspects je sais je prends un exemple qui
peut apparaître anecdotique et mesquin
mais quand le président macron se
déplace il ya régulièrement 2000 crs qui
sont mobilisés quand il se déplace en
province
est ce que c'est bien utile de mobiliser
deux mille fonctionnaires pour le
déplacement d'un seul homme
d'une façon générale est ce que le train
de vie de l'état doit rester en
permanence en dehors des politiques de
réduction des dépenses publiques ou
est-ce que vous êtes on devrait s'y
intéresser
est-ce que l'audiovisuel public ne
mériterait pas d'être à peu repris en
main c'est une question aussi que je
pose est à terme qu'en général on n'aime
pas beaucoup surtout les journalistes
quand on a repris en main bah bien sûr
mais je crois qu'il ya des choses à
faire sur le plan des dépenses il ya des
choses à faire et des économies à
trouver et françois fillon le proposait
est ce que je veux dire c'est que alors
même qu'il avait subi à l'époque une
campagne de déstabilisation et même de
destruction sans précédent à mon avis
pour un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il a quand même fait
quasiment jeu égal avec les deux
finalistes et le troisième le quatrième
candidat jean-luc mélenchon donc je
crois que c'est un thème qui celui-là
est très porteur la remise en place d'un
état qui fonctionne d'un état qui est
sain sur le plan de ses dépenses et un
peu plus de libéralisme un peu plus de
liberté économique un peu moins de frais
de charges sur les salaires
il a utilisé les deux
flexibilisation du marché du travail et
réduction des services publics qui sont
deux leitmotivs
moi j'arrive jal pour la réduction des
services publics non mais ça que j'ai
compris qu'il faut réduire les dépenses
publiques on peut même les augmenté dans
les services publics mais en tout cas
c'est le son on retrouve ça à peu près
dans tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédés moi il me semble de mauvais que
vous avez raison les services publics
diminuent mais la dépense publique
augmente c'est simple paradoxe français
en réalité pas seulement françaises
c'est arrivé en grèce s'est abîmé mais
ça aussi c'est quelque chose c'est un
vrai problème
la droite est arrivé en permanence avec
on va enlever le un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires on va etc et on sait bien
il me semble pas que les français en
tout cas une majorité de français sous
ils soient favorables
on a bien compris la position de charles
cros civile mais quelle est la vôtre là
dessus je vous dis je suis très investi
sur cette question parce que les toute
la droite est endetté sur cette question
voudrait aller mais moi c'est pas moche
il est dans l'autre enjeu électoral donc
c'est vrai j'ai par exemple prouvant que
les gens plus âgés c'est vrai mais
charles a une position très tranchée moi
j'ai du mal à être tranchée pour
plusieurs raisons parce que déjà je
pense que le fait politique de ces
dernières années c'est la crise des
gilets jaunes léger les jaunes il disait
quand même quelque chose sur ces aspects
là ils demandaient pas spécialement d il
ya une sorte de réaction
d'incompréhension au moment des 10
milliards annoncée par macron où les
gens se sont dit oh mon moi j'entendais
beaucoup de réactions de gens qui
disaient on demandait pas l'aumône en
réalité donc la dépense publique
aujourd'hui même même quand elle est
généreuse je pense notamment au système
de la protection sociale
en fait elle est assez mal vécue par les
gens qui ont l'impression qu'on leur
donne la becquée que l'état leur donne
la becquée donc je vais être d'accord
moi sur ce point là on a un état obèse
on a un état qui se croient chargé de
tout alors qu'en réalité la société doit
pouvoir s'organiser parfois tout seul et
on a une dépense publique en fait qui
est un peu folle moi je suis un peu un
peu passionné et passionné et surtout
très remonté contre l'organisation
territoriale et 11 ont fait ça ajouter
des couches régulièrement chaque
président veut avoir sa réforme
territoriale et à la fin on a des
régions des départements des communes
des communautés de communes etc avec une
décision où on sent un sentiment de
participer à la décision de la part des
citoyens qui c'est qui qui s'érode
complètement les gens ont l'impression
d'être super loin de l'endroit où on a
pris les décisions pour leur vie mais
pourtant des dépenses de fonctionnement
qui sont énormes donc je suis d'accord
avec charles je pense qu' il faudrait je
suis incapable de dire où en tout cas
j'en ai cité quelques exemples mais j'ai
pas de programme présidentiel
il faudrait être capable de faire
réduire le train de vie de l'état
maintenant sur la sur la question de du
libéralisme
je suis pas parfait je suis pas
complètement d'accord même je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec le fait que le
protectionnisme est une catastrophe et
aujourd'hui c'est une demande des
peuples il faut donc la prendre en
compte c'est à dire que vous entendez
par protectionnisme les guerres
économiques qui sont menées par donald
trump qui a en effet protectionnistes et
par le président chinois qui rend en
effet protectionnistes face à l'europe
moi je les gens tire une conclusion pour
l'instant ça n'a pas pénaliser outre
mesure et l'économie américaine alors
qu'on avait promis que si pas non plus
l'économie chinoise alors qu'on avait
promis que si en revanche l'europe se
fait dépecer et quasiment par ces pays
qui ont en fait une stratégie de
protection est aussi une stratégie
offensive
moi je regrette juste et en français et
en europe et 1 qu' on est on ait eu des
vues chimérique pendant des années en
croyant que l'europe tel qu'on l'a conçu
c'est à dire sans frontières pour
l'accélération des échanges allaient
nous protéger de quoi que ce soit ça
n'est pas le cas je pense que c'est un
des enjeux auxquels elle doit répondre
maintenant il faut qu'elle rétablisse
des frontières mais moi je pense qu il
faut qu elle rétablit pas la verrière
rétablisse des frontier mais rétablir
des frontières ça veut pas dire arrêter
des échanges à l'intérieur de l'europe
mais pourquoi pas je vais vous dire moi
j'ai quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
marqué à quelques années parce que les
frontières ça c'est pas que pour
l'économie c'est que on avait un
gouvernement socialiste donc qui nous
expliquait que c'était complètement
illusoire d'imaginer que les frontières
pouvait être une solution une quelconque
solution au problème qu'on avait et
c'est qu'il ya eu des attentats du
bataclan et le soir même
françois hollande a rétabli la frontière
avec l'allemagne et j'ai trouvé ça
fascinant comme symbole c'est à dire que
c'est très mal mais quand il ya un
problème en fait c'est tout à coup c'est
bien ça la solution
justement je vous interromps parce que
tu es la deuxième question et je pense
que c'est maintenant qu'il faut que je
me la pose est-ce qu'il faut choisir
l'europe pour l'indépendance nationale
là aussi c'est un c'est un choix qui
semble cornélien je vais alors justement
je te réponds l'europe reste la première
puissance économique du monde
on est tout le temps là les européens à
s'auto flageller on est le la zone la
plus riche du monde et probablement la
plus influente sait on si on additionne
toutes nos influences ensemble quand
l'europe et fort est ce que vous êtes
sûr quand on additionne toutes nos
influences sont des plus influents que
la chine ou les états unis et vous quand
pendant la présidence tournante de
nicolas sarkozy de l'union européenne on
a quand même résolu une crise en géorgie
on avait tout à coup une europe qui
étaient écoutés alors c'est sûr on n'a
pas la même armée que les états unis
donc c'est un détail qui évidemment
n'est pas négligeable mais en moins
l'europe reste la première puissance
économique du monde et moi je suis
toujours assez révolté quand on utilise
les attentats le terrorisme pour
justifier des mesures qui en fait ne
sont pas commandés par les attentats et
le terrorisme typiquement on va pas
mettre fin à l'espace schengen qui est
quand même un progrès inestimable canton
quand on a en tête l'histoire de
l'europe
on va pas mettre fin à l'espace schengen
parce qu'il ya eu des attentats mais
déjà y compris des attentats terrible
comme des attentats du bataclan déjà
dire que ce n'est pas une bonne idée de
la part de françois hollande de rétablir
une frontière avec l'allemagne ou
peut-être avec la belgique en
l'occurrence je ne crois pas du tout moi
je pense que pour répondre à votre
question la souveraineté nationale c'est
très bien mais je pense que la france
est d'autant plus forte et souveraine
que sa souveraineté s'exerce à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et en
partenariat avec les pays de l'union
européenne ce qui se passe les états
unis
vont pas vers une souveraineté de chacun
de leur état on n'a pas des relations
diplomatiques particulièrement poussée
avec la californie ou l'arkansas
donc évidemment que à mon avis nous tout
notre intérêt est d'aller moi je suis
fondamentalement pro-européen je pense
que je continue de penser que l'union
européenne c'est l'avenir et qu'on est
beaucoup plus forts évidemment quand on
est à l'échelle de l'europe que quand on
est à l'échelle française ça me paraît
être un élément d'un exemple un exemple
d'un moment où on a été plus fort je
viens de le donner
l'adjoint géorgie l'invasion de la
géorgie l'exemple inverse c'est nicolas
sarkozy lui-même d'ailleurs a expliqué
que c'est parce qu'il à assumer un
leadership qui était au nom de l'europe
mais c'est lui qui a décidé d'exercer
style de renault de l'europe mais non
mais souffrent en tant que président de
l'union européenne c'est absolument
incomparable
moi je vais je fais la lecture
exactement inverse en réalité déjà faut
pas comparer les etats-unis qui sont une
fédération d'états avec nous qui sommes
un vieux continent avec un modèle d'état
nation que le monde entier quand même à
copier pendant pendant très longtemps
premièrement deuxièmement ensuite il
faut quand même voir si les à-coups
qu'est ce que c'est l'europe aujourd'hui
ce sont des intérêts vous habitez la d
intérêt qui s'additionnent les intérêts
contradictoires en permanence qui ne
s'additionne quasiment jamais et comme
mes intérêts sont peut-être
contradictoires avec ceux de mon voisin
de palier mais c'est pas pour ça que je
peux pas être son allié c'est pas pour
ça qu'on peut pas avoir la même route et
par notre ils veulent pas pareil au
moment de la reprise c'est pas pour ça
que oui mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on
paye pas nos charges ensemble par
exemple par bon de venir à des exemples
de projets il y est ça c'est pas un
problème qu'on ait des intérêts
contradictoires c'est pas pour ça qu'on
ne peut pas être allié on a aujourd'hui
un enjeu je prends un exemple on a un
enjeu aujourd'hui de lutte contre les
états unis sur la question des gars
femmes il faut leur expliquer que c'est
que en fait le dépeçage de l'europe et
le pillage de données personnelles est
terminée vous l'avocat ça doit vous
plaire
il dépasse pas les gaffes adepes pas
l'union européenne et les vocaux la
replay d'affaires de facebook google et
amazon ebay paraissent l'europe
ils font quelque chose à me dire sont
quasiment de l'espionnage ils payent pas
leurs impôts ici en revanche on met un
énorme marché pour eux et c'est bon on a
un bon jeu pas d'être épaisse au
contraire tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que facilite nos vies moi les
gars fans d'accord tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'aujourd'hui il
faudrait se battre contre les gars et
leur imposer à l'échelle européenne bien
on peut modifier le traité par leurs
impôts mais sinon pourquoi se bat contre
acs est déjà une énorme
une énorme un élan de combat winamp
victoire que pour l'instant on n'a pas
obtenu non mais je finis lui sur cet
exemple c'est un très intéressant au
moment où on commence à se battre à ce
moment là on a un problème nous français
avec l'allemagne par exemple qui est
dépendante des états unis pour ses
exportations qui tout à coup
ce fait tapis sur le museau en tout cas
à la menace de faire taper sur le museau
et qui ne défend plus nos intérêts ça
n'existe pas les intérêts européens en
réalité à l'intérêt de l'europe nous
avons des intérêts nationaux et nous
passons notre vie à nous diviser je veux
dire et puis pour finir sur schengen
pardon parce que vos l'exemple du
terrorisme ne vous plaît pas mais
aujourd'hui par exemple je discutais
tout à l'heure avec une eurodéputée
nadine morano qui me racontait qu'elle a
visités ya très peu de temps un centre
de rétention administrative en france
qu'en moselle je crois elle m'a expliqué
qu'en fait on avait un budget
aujourd'hui monstrueux pour les retours
en avion à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen des gens qui sont déboutés du
droit d'asile mais qui reviennent par le
fameux processus de dublin vous savez
dans le pays où ils sont arrivés un
exemple un migrant carrière en italie
qui va jusqu'à la france qui a arrêté en
france qu'on décide d'expulser on en
voit en italie donc on ne paye un vol à
l'intérieur de l'italie et on le
retrouve en france quelques semaines
plus tard parce qu'il refait le même
trajet bon schengen ça ne fonctionne pas
ça n'existe pas ça ne met là à l'exemple
que vous donnez pardon mais ça ne va
rien changer
si on sort de l'espace schengen on va
quand même le renvoyer en italie même si
on prêtait s'il arrive à rentrer mais si
on rétablit les frontières mais
imaginons qu'il arrive à passer
puisqu'on sait que les frontières elles
ne sont pas complètement est en jeu à
deux en italie et simplement on va payer
l'avion sur des frais français au lieu
de le payer sur des sur un budget
européen
ben se serait prononcé le mot intérêts
alors je sais pas si vous pensez que ya
de nouveau une lutte des classes en
france on est le signe de la lutte des
classes est ce qu'elle est repartie vous
parlez des gilet jaune tout à l'heure et
dans ce cas là il va falloir peut-être
que la droite choisit son combat lors de
kid la droite doit-elle le défendre les
intérêts en priorité est-ce que elle
doit défendre en priorité les intérêts
de ceux qui réussissent en espérant que
ils vont attirer ils vont en tout cas
les autres vont en profiter en termes
d'emploi on va dire ou est-ce qu'au
contraire il faut qu'elles défendent en
priorité les intérêts des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes
on va dire et qui donc la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat semble se vérifier
d'année en année est ce qu'il ya un
choix à faire là aussi entre le 1 % et
les autres pour faire très très simple
ou ou entre les entreprises et les
salariés
on a l'impression que là aussi la droite
ne sait plus quoi choisir ne sait plus
si tu es marine le pen le rassemblement
national est très clair c'est le parti
des classes populaires notamment des
ouvriers des employés et ça ne bouge pas
depuis maintenant nombre d'années le
reste de la droite ça a l'air moins
claires ce qui reste une droite en
dehors du rassemblement national c'est
ça qui est un peu compliqué ça que ce
qui reste des républicains dieu sait que
moi je suis attaché à ce parti j'ai
beaucoup couvert les républicains et
j'ai eu beaucoup couvert sarkozy fillon
et c'est aujourd'hui objectivement vous
avez quand même le sentiment d'une lente
agonie qui se termine un peu en
capilotade et partagé entre toutes ces
pour tout c'est le choix et de qui
semble à et qui sur lequel vous n'êtes
pas réconcilié vous de vous non et mieux
ça c'était pour ça pose là bas était
intéressant mais écoutez moi je pense
que le le le rôle de en tout cas
historiquement le rôle de la droite
c'était du côté des classes populaires
le gaullisme était du côté des classes
populaires pompidou n'a pas fait de mal
aux classes populaires
ça a commencé à changer avec giscard et
il ya une réconciliation avec nicolas
sarkozy une sorte de rendez vous manqués
et aujourd'hui on en est là maintenant
c'est marine le pen qui l'est qui les
représentent et c'est pas vous parler de
réconciliation électorale électorale
absolument l'a pas forcément dans les
faits non mais je suis vraiment d'accord
avec vous écoutez je pense qu'en tout
cas pour répondre dans l'otan ça votre
question choisir les 1% en pensant
qu'ils vont faire locomotive du pays je
pense que c'est une folie pour plusieurs
raisons parce que déjà l'individualisme
qui s'est imprégnée dans nos sociétés
fait qu'aujourd'hui si vous réussissez
si vous avez la chance de réussir dans
un monde où globalement dans un pays où
globalement on se paupérise vous pensez
à vous sauvez à sauver votre famille et
vous pensez pas aider votre pays donc
vous ne fait absolument pas de
locomotive
je connais plein d'entrepreneurs très
méritants qui ont une fibre sociale etc
je pense que c'est quand même une espèce
en voie de disparition ensuite je la
politique ses 107 le bien commun dont
quand vous êtes président un pays même
si vous êtes élu par les 1% en tout cas
par parler les gens les plus aisés de ce
pays votre rôle c'est de raccrocher les
classes populaires de ce pays et puis
les plus modestes évidemment au wagon
entre guillemets et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
en fait la droite devrait ne devrait se
préoccuper de ne parler qu'aux gilet
jaune en réalité je pense que ce serait
vraiment ça il essaye aujourd'hui de
parier sur un échec de macron qui
décevrait les milieux d'affaires pour
tout à coup redevenir le parti de là
c'est le pari que font un certain les
républicains aujourd'hui
en dix ans il va pas assez loin sur les
retraites regardez sur l' isf il aurait
pu faire mieux et c'est la vérité c'est
que je pense que leur sujet ça devrait
être de parler en plus léger les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui se lèvent tôt c'était des
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qu'ils
demandaient pas spécialement conviennent
justement leur donner la becquée il
aurait dû leur expliquer qu'en fait
aujourd'hui quand on sait quand on se
lève tôt quand on travaille et quand on
donne tout on a des moyens de s'en
sortir la vérité c'est que le cri
d'alarmé gilet jaune c'était qu'il n'y
arrivait plus malgré ça moi tout ce que
j'ai rencontré à l'époque sur sur des
ronds points disait que étaient des gens
qui travaillaient déjà et disait qu'en
fait il était pénalisé par un système où
il aurait été il aurait été mieux ou
presque mieux s'il n'avait pas travaillé
et qu'ils avaient bénéficié des aides ça
c'est un pays qui va plus et en fait le
moins pour moi la droite devrait en
avoir un discours qu à destination des
classes populaires
or elle a abandonné pensant qu'elles
sont acquises à marine le pen advitam
eternam ce qui peut être vrai mais bon
c'est un pari sur c'est un pari
incertain et pensant aussi que la
bourgeoisie va se détourner de macron je
pense que la bourgeoisie beaucoup plus
accrochée à mâcon que les classes
populaires ne sont attachés à une classe
moyenne
il ya une classe moyenne que la droite
devrait défendre et qui aujourd'hui est
entre est en train quand même de
basculer globalement enfin
l'augmentation des scores du
rassemblement national c'est les
électeurs que la droite laisse partir
moi je crois pas aux mirages sur les
électeurs de mélenchon qui tout à coup
bascule en masse je pense qu'il reste
une forme de clivage droite gauche et le
départ des classes moyennes vers marine
le pen c'est parce que la droite a
arrêté de leur parler tout simplement
pas continuer là-dessus serait assez
d'accord je pense que la droite doit
parler
au peuple est exclusivement aux peuples
et certainement pas à cette histoire de
premier de cordée au 1 % etc
je vois pas pourquoi les premiers de
cordée et les 1% qui ont déjà toutes les
manettes entre leurs mains aurait en
plus à leurs services le président de la
république le gouvernement l'état et
l'administration
je pense d'ailleurs que en réalité
l'erreur majeure des manuels macron
c'est d'avoir donné le sentiment à tort
ou à raison d'être le président d'un
pourcent justement d'être un peu leurs
mandataires
quand ils privatisent les aéroports de
paris pour les donner au groupe vinci
c'est pour moi c'est une erreur mais
majeur les aéroports de paris c'est par
définition quelque chose qui doit rester
la propriété de la puissance même
l'analyser râle c'est à dire des banques
mais bien sûr pourtant vous adhérez à la
gageure mois ce qui croyez moi vite vous
vous dites j'aimerais bien que ce soit
une autre entreprise qui vient ça on est
on n'aimait pas si faux pas il faut
avoir un bagage cabine on peut être
l'idée qu'on peut être libéral et bien
sûr avoir le sens de la sécurité de la
france et du fait qu'il ya des endroits
qui sont stratégiques et qui n'ont pas
du tout vocation à rentrer dans le giron
du secteur privé de toute manière les
aéroports ne nous coûtait même pas
d'argent ils rapportaient de l'argent à
l'état donc pour moi ça c'est un cadeau
à des intérêts privés qui ont fait
pression pour obtenir ce cadeau et
qu'ils ont obtenu on a dit la même chose
au moment des privatisations en 86 vous
en souvenez vous êtes peut-être trop
jeune bout j'ai fait planer en 80 gr
clair quand même chirac qui a été
premier ministre de cohabitation et
françois mitterrand et edouard balladur
aux finances l économie des finances et
les privatisations n'a parlé des noyaux
pour pour surtout que ça ne partent pas
à l'étranger en tout cas je crois voilà
je crois qu'il ya des entreprises qui ne
doivent pas être privatisée des secteurs
qui ne doivent pas être privatisée
typiquement il m'arrive régulièrement de
tempêter contre la sncf
parce qu'en général on pour peu qu'on
ait pas telles cartes tel machin on
tombe sur des gens assez obtus qui qui
peuvent nous agacer on a des
régulièrement des problèmes sur les
lignes etc qui peuvent vous axez
néanmois jeunes à dire pas du tout aux
discours
or selon lequel il faudrait purement et
simplement la privatiser tout ça parce
qu'elle ne serait pas rentable
ou en tout cas ne pas la privatiser mal
à garder public et l'amener quand même à
la rentabilité je pense que typiquement
ce qui fait partie de la france de son
identité c'est aussi sa douceur
c'est aussi qu'on est un pays où on a le
sus le souci des plus faibles et où on a
typiquement les petites gares les
petites lignes et c'est que les
maquereaux nist ferme parce que il ya
mon avis ils servent quand même certains
inter acculé ma chronique tous ceux qui
les ont précédés ont fermé les petites
gares et les lignes secondaires en
l'occurrence on a fait le pari de la
huayra longtemps et on a tenu
qui a créé ces quarts mais le karma kron
c'est lui qui est à l'origine donc je
crois voilà que la droite elle doit être
du côté du peuple
elle doit être du côté des plus faibles
tout simplement ce que le politique
c'est l'état et l'état de qui en a le
plus besoin ce sont les plus faibles
c'est le peuple c'est certainement pas
les 1% et les premiers de cordée
donc je pars à lancer le débat d'avant
champ mais pardon mais le peuple qu'on
pourrait en tout cas les enquêtes
d'opinion qui sont réalisés sur des
sujets précis pas sur les intentions de
vote ils demandent du protectionnisme
ils demandent ils demandent des
frontière au sénat mais c'est aussi pour
ça que moi je tiens je sais pas ça c'est
ce que disent les protectionnistes et
des bacilles et s'ouvrait driss
d'opinion c'est ce qui pourrait se
tromper
j'entends nicolas dupont aignan dire ça
et serrage je sais pas moi j'ai
l'impression que les français ils sont
quand même encore pour l'europe
quand on prend les sondages ils sont
exempts pas du tout tourné le dos à ça
quand on leur demande de voter ils
votent non ils ont voté non en 2005 mais
depuis il ya eu d'autres votes chez
d'autres élections et a eu que des
candidats pro européens qui ont été élus
quand même aux trois dernières élections
présidentielles et qui étaient plutôt
des pro-européens très affirmé nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande emmanuel
macron tous les trois dans leur campagne
présidentielle se sont montré résolument
pro européen donc je ne suis pas sûr que
les que les que les peuples pense que
vous dites
on va faire une pause juste on a une
minute
si vous deviez faire la différence
aujourd'hui entre ce que l'on qualifie
d' extrême droite parce qu'après tout
marine le pen dit qu'elle n'est pas
l'extrême droite mais la droite est ce
que l'on qualifie de droit qui a encore
une différence
enfin il ya une différence marquée pour
vous pouvez
2 les électorats c'est une différence
sociologique c'est une différence je
pense même de revenus en fait c'est à
dire de revenus diplôme le diplôme
absolument ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment marqué et ensuite il ya une
différence historique certes le parti de
marine le pen n'est pas le même du tout
historiquement que le parti de l'est en
termes de discours et en avant il y
avait une différence sur la keynote
c'étaient les immigrés enfin c'est
encore vrai aujourd'hui on sur la
question de l'immigration c'est pas vrai
sur la question de l'islam c'est pas
vrai ça n'est que de la différence
n'existe plus et il ya une différence
sur la question sur la question
économique et sur le protectionnisme et
c'est marine le pen à ce discours
affirmé cohérent et où les républicains
comme on le dit depuis tout à l'heure en
fait sont beaucoup de mal à se
positionner et ne savent pas il ya des
gens qui pensent plutôt comme marine le
pen il ya des gens qui pensent comme
plutôt comme macron à l'intérieur de ce
parti qui aujourd'hui un peu une auberge
espagnole ont fait une pause on continue
ce débat
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique ça
va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avec un
beaucoup plus à perdre que les états
unis je suis pas convaincu tout de même
que le jeu ne soit pas plus équilibré
qu'il n'y paraît vous avez un certain
nombre de secteurs d'activité aux états
unis qui ont été lourdement impactés
s'aperçoit qu'ils sont en train de
perdre leur statut de superpuissance et
unique superpuissance en la chine est un
pays qui peut beaucoup plus rapidement
que n'importe quel autre pays du monde
se passer des états unis et entraîné
avec elle en plus un certain nombre
d'autres pays européens qu c'est
aujourd'hui la chine qui remet en cause
l'hégémonie américaine
[Musique]
et l'actualité c'est évidemment le
corona virus là aussi c'est un peu un
effet de la mondialisation
mon ami quand même plus d'un mois avant
que l'information remonte de wuhan
jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers cas
du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre dans les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
se faire sortir notamment en france à
cause des touristes non mais il ya eu
quand même des mesures très autoritaire
de prise bien sûr mais pour pouvoir
stopper la contagion
il n'y a que des mesures autoritaires
qui peuvent être prises est-ce que tu as
un message là en direction de trumpf
c'est constant chez les chinois depuis
toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau vous ai mis deux
cents ans à le faire alors venez pas
nous donner des leçons alors là ce qui a
pas là aussi une autre leçon c'est que
la mondialisation dont on a dit pic et
pendre
on n'est pas très bien outillé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand une épidémie vient
de chine
bah elle se répand dans le monde entier
[Musique]
quelle valeur pour la droite on continue
notre débat entre l'avocat charles
consigny et le directeur de la rédaction
de valeurs actuelles
geoffroy le jeune ils ont 31 et 30 ans
ma question maintenant ce sera sur la
liberté l'identité on dirait que là
aussi la liberté ça a toujours été une
valeur pas seulement de droite mais il y
avait une idée à droite qui étaient
autour de la liberté
et aujourd'hui on a l'impression de plus
en plus c'est l'identité ne serait ce
que parce que vous venez de le dire sur
les immigrés sur le rapport avec
l'immigration par exemple le double des
le discours de la droite s'est calqué
sur celui de l'extrême droite depuis
quelques temps or ya toujours des
libertaires à droite ya des gens qui
continuent de penser que on a le droit
de que les citoyens sont libres en
matière de moeurs de religion de
comportement de morale de culture ils
font ce qu'ils veulent l'état n'a pas à
s'en soucier
et puis aussi une frange de la droite
qui pensent qu'au contraire l'état doit
préserver une certaine identité qu'il
qualifie de française et c'est ça et
pétales tout à fait raison de se soucier
à la fois notre manière de pratiquer
notre religion de s'habiller de
de faire des enfants avec un papa et une
maman etc etc
alors là aussi comment résoudre cette
opposition geoffrey lejeune est ici
défaut choisir de quel côté faut-il
choisir s'il faut choisir selon les
termes que vous me dire moi je me place
du côté de l'identité mais en fait
notamment parce que je considère que la
liberté ça n'est pas par bond pour votre
émission mais ça n'est pas interdit
d'interdire et jouir sans entraves je
pense que ça conduit en fait à
l'asservissement dire que moi je suis
contre cette vision qu'on a hérité des
années des années 60 et de mai-68
notamment puis qu'en fait c'est beaucoup
développée après ainsi vous avenue des
états unis consistant à dire qu'en gros
quand il n'y aura plus aucune barrière
tout ira mieux et on sera libre je pense
que c'est pas vrai je pense qu'on est
libre à l'intérieur d'un cadre je pense
qu'on est libre en respectant des règles
une norme commune etc
et donc c'est sans doute peut-être
derrière francs en tout cas c'est le
point de divergence avec charles qui
m'est venu en premier parce qu'il a
soutenu le le mariage pour tous qui l'a
pas empêché d'être d'être qualifiés
d'homophobes très récemment par nos amis
de sciences po lille et moi je suis
résolument opposés à ça parce que je
considère si vous voulez que en fait une
société ne peut pas se construire avec
avec des mensonges et notamment là en
l'occurrence on le voit en ce moment
avec le débat sur la pma l'idée qu'on
peut tout à coup faire avoir un enfant
qu'il n'est pas le père qu'ils soient
privés perdre à la naissance c'est moi
je souhaite en rester là dans
l'argumentation en fait à partir du
moment où on fait ça peu importe tous
les arguments sur la liberté en fait je
considère qu'on est en train de créer un
monde complètement instable
donc pour répondre à votre question
binaire binaire je me place du côté de
l'identité parce que je pense qu'il ya
un cadre préservé sans lequel rien n'est
possible
charles consigny moi je pense que la
france est beaucoup plus qu'un pays une
civilisation que c'est une des plus
belles civilisations du monde que c'est
à la fois une civilisation d'art de
vivre avec son vin son son expertise
dans des domaines du luxe sont son
architecture une civilisation naturel
avec ses paysages qui sont parmi les
plus variés du monde
une civilisation aussi de grandeur un
pays qui a su être grands à travers
l'histoire à la fois par ses conquêtes
mais aussi par là la noblesse de ses
idées et par quelques grands personnages
le dernier en date étant le général de
gaulle et je crois que dans la lah
l'adn de cette civilisation française il
y a quand même la liberté
il y à la liberté il y à la préservation
de l'état de droit
il y a la possibilité pour chacun d'être
libre et évidemment que quand on
commence à me dire que l'état va se
mêler du mode de vie des citoyens moi
c'est quelque chose qui me gêne même les
80 km/heure d'edouard philippe c'est
quelque chose qui me gêne
de quoi se mêle-t-il que ne foutent ils
la paient aux citoyens français
néanmoins je suis pas aveugle et je sais
qu'au nom de certains dogmes ont réduit
la liberté insidieusement des citoyens
français
je sais que par exemple une conception
rigoriste de l'islam a tendance à se
répandre à certains endroits du
territoire français et que sous couvert
d'exercer librement
le culte musulman en réalité
insidieusement ont réduit la liberté de
citoyen musulman je pense aux femmes
qu'on oblige à s'habiller d'une certaine
façon qu'on oblige à rester chez elle à
certains moments qu'on empêche d'aller
boire un café dans le café du coin il ya
ces cafés en france qui se multiplient
où il n'y a que des hommes
et tout ça je ne l'admets pas non plus
de la mède m'étais pas non plus pour les
juifs traditionalistes dont les femmes
portent des perruques et qui a jeté gym
je sais pour toutes les femmes ça n'est
pas seulement pour moi moi je suis
toujours inquiet quand on quand un dogue
me conduit à réduire la liberté des
citoyens et dans ces cas là je pense
qu'en effet l'état peut intervenir par
exemple quand il ya eu le débat sur le
burqini moi je suis désolé mais j'avais
trouvé ridicule les cris d'orfraie des
de certains de certains et notamment
d'avocats contre l'interdiction du
burkina sur les plages mais je pense du
conseil d'état aussi j'en ai mêlée qui a
dit qu'on avait encore le droit de
s'habiller comme vous voulez bien sûr
mais moi je aller à la limite si j'avais
eu à juger
j'aurais été de l'avis du conseil d'état
mais j'étais pas particulièrement
choqués par les arrêtés municipaux qui
disait le burqini en france on est
désolé mais c'est pas notre manière de
vivre ça n'est pas nos moeurs on
considère que c'est une manière de
réduire le
la liberté de la femme etc donc donc
voilà je suis pas dans une position
caricaturale de l'hiver verte libérale
mais pas imbibé remet jamais là où je
mettrais nuancé que je pense qu'en
france où on est déjà tellement sous le
poids de l'état où on est tellement
contrôler où on est tellement
réglementés où on est tellement à tous
les étages de nos vies en fait
driver si je puis dire si je peux
utiliser un anglicisme de libéral par
l'état je pense qu'en fait on se doit
d'être libertaire et que la situation
est telle en france qu'on devrait être
libertaire je prends un exemple par
exemple et gilet jaune on a parlé de dg
joue en réalité cette révolte qui était
une révolte populaire contre ce qui a
été perçu je pense comme une espèce de
trahison des élites ou tout à coup les
gens dit non mais là ça suffit vous
n'allez pas continuer comme ça
indéfiniment on descend dans la rue on
n'est pas content cette révolte elle a
été matée par le système étatique elle a
été matée par la police à qui il faut
bien le dire on a un peut délivrer un
blanc-seing en mode
allez-y les gars tout le monde a vu
l'article du monde qui a beaucoup
circulé avec des citations de supérieurs
hiérarchiques dans la polique allez-y
les gars vous pouvez y aller ça fera
réfléchir les suivants on n'a pas
poursuivi
les policiers qui avaient commis des
violences inadmissibles on a les scènes
du burger king sur les champs-elysées
avec des gens qui sont littéralement
tabassé par des crs pas de poursuites
pas de sanction et ça a été aussi mater
par la justice par le système judiciaire
qui a accepté de d'emboîter le pas à la
police et qui envoyait notamment
beaucoup de gilet jaune en détention
provisoire en fait pour essayer de
casser ce mouvement pour dissuader les
gens et là je démens de la prison ferme
c est plus des peines de prison ferme en
comparution immédiate avec mandat de
dépôt à la barre c'est à dire vous allez
directement en prison même si votre
peine est faible et donc là je dis on se
doit d'être libertaire face à des
situations comme ça c'est pour ça que je
poserai pas les deux je suis conscient
des menaces sur l'identité je pense que
la france a une identité je pense
qu'elle a le droit de défendre son
identité parce qu'elle est une
civilisation mais je pense aussi que on
a une espèce de basculement et qu'au nom
de on est pas des libertaires et c'est
en fait ont fini par permettre des
atteintes aux libertés qui sont
contraires à l'identité de la france je
pense que l'identité de la france c'est
aussi la liberté est alors justement
est-ce qu'il faut continuer de réduire
les
rt individuel au nom de la sécurité non
la sécurité en général c'est à
qu'utilise beaucoup la droite la gauche
s'est mise à l'utiliser aussi ces
dernières années enfin quand elle était
au pouvoir
mais au départ on se disait que c'était
plutôt le refrain de la droite
alors oui dit non mais je connais le
point de vue de l'avocat et je sais
qu'on sera pas du tout d'accord et c'est
bien pour nous ce que chacun dans votre
rôle moi je pense oui je veux dire
pourquoi je pense qu'en réalité cette
question de réduire les limite les
libertés individuelles ne nous menace
pas du tout et qu'en fait aujourd'hui on
est dans autre chose qui font qu'il faut
nommer en fait c'est que l'état de droit
que charles défendez tout à l'heure et
qu'il continuera à défendre après que
j'ai parlé il n'est pas le seul à
défendre comme à gauche quand on sent
encore partout mais ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'état de droit est en fait
aujourd'hui une gigantesque mâchoire
dans laquelle se fracasse justement
notre identité et la possibilité de
continuer à vivre sereinement dans ce
pays je m'explique moi je ne tolère pas
qu'au nom de l'état de droit
aujourd'hui la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme nous empêche
d'expulser un islamistes étrangers en
l'occurrence un imam algérien il ya
quelques années au nom des droits de
l'homme que les droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui c'est devenu plus important
par l'état de droit que la protection
des gens qui vivent sur ce dont ce pays
bas et qu'ils n'ont pas à subir
l'influencé de ce prêcheur c'était pire
que ça la fille s'il était quasiment
terroristes je ne tolère pas aujourd'hui
à chaque fois que qu'un attentat ou un
passage à l'acte et c'est de découvrir
qu'il était surveillé qu'il était il
avait fait de la prison mais qu'il avait
qu'il était sorti et qu'en réalité à un
moment donné un durcissement de notre
politique pénale vis-à-vis de ces gens
là aurait pu permettre au mépris de ce
qu'on appelle d'état droit de sauver
peut-être des vies voilà mais je veux
dire je raisonne pour le coup à
l'anglo-saxonne boris johnson boris
johnson a dit à quelques jours au sujet
du dernière à grand pas qui est qui
s'est produit en angleterre
à un moment donné quand la loi
fonctionne pas il faut changer la loi et
ça provoque pas de cris d'orfraie il
faut vraiment qu'on soit contaminée par
cette espèce de conception gauchisante
de l'état de droit pour considérer qu'il
va falloir se battre au au prix de serre
au prix de vies et au prix d'une menace
permanente sur notre sécurité va falloir
se battre pour préserver ce truc qui
rend personne rue pardonnez moi qui ne
donne pas de résultat donc moi je veux
juste que vous m'expliquer où est la
vraie menace sur nos libertés
individuelles
elle en durcissant les détentions la
rétention le l'expulsion de ces gens qui
nous qui aujourd'hui les actuellement
même en mettant en prison les fichiers
mais par exemple - rodez compte de ce
que vous dites est ce sont des gens qui
n'ont rien fait je me rend absolument
mais donc que l'on surveille au cas où
ils menaceraient de faire quelque chose
et qu'on arrive mais en plus complexes
pour certains mais vous proposer de
mettre en prison des gens qui n'ont rien
fait mais qui n'ont pas rien fait sinon
encore rien fait alors ils ont bison pas
ils ont tué personne ne l'ont pas rien
fait ils ont fréquenté des mosquées
c'est la fille au regard des et donc
commis aucune je laisse la rocade et
personnes voulaient juste qu'on soit
bien d'accord sur ce que vous dites bon
qu'il y ait pas de malentendu je pense
que l on peut quand même écarté tout de
suite l'idée de mettre les gens en
prison sur la base d'un simple fichage
précisément bonjour moi je suis désolé
mais si demain en france on commence à
mettre les gens en prison sur la
décision d'un officier de police
judiciaire
sans passage devant un tribunal je fais
mes valises je veux dire ça veut dire
que la france est morte le moment où on
fait ça c'est qu'on est mort on est
foutu non mais vous prenez vraiment
vraiment l'exemple moi je vous dis à mes
réfléchir c'est ça non mais d'accord
c'est ça mais il ya bien et j'ai
plusieurs catégories dans le fichier oui
alors s'afficher s il y en a qui sont en
berne le rouge alors la pop ensuite
prenez vous prenez volontairement cet
exemple leur disant henry donc tout à
coup c'est minority report on va en
prison avant d'avoir fait quoi que ce
soit et c'est j'entends l'objection mais
j'ai envie de vous répondre
pardonnez moi il ya il ya des cas quand
même extrêmement concret on relâche
aujourd'hui des djihadistes par exemple
qui sont allés en syrie compte
d'ailleurs au nom de quoi on a été
obligé de les reprendre
bon c'est un autre débat et on les
relâche aujourd'hui les premiers sont en
train de sortir de prison maintenant
qu'est coop bon état de droit je vais
libérer blé d'abord non mais je réponds
de toute façon c'est des gens qui sont
surveillés
même s'ils ressortent parce qu'ils ont
purgé leur peine
mais enfin il ya quand même des
principes de base vous êtes condamné
parce que vous avez commis une
infraction aller en prison vous condamne
à une certaine peine à l'issue de votre
peine
vous pouvez sortir de prison sinon
encore une fois on est mort on n'est
plus dans un système qui est vivable si
vous devez rester en prison après avoir
fini votre peine parce qu'on se dit que
peut être vous recommenceriez on n'est
plus dans un système qui étonnamment
ensuite là où à mon avis la proposition
elle est folle c'est
de toute manière le système s'est
énormément durci y compris en permettant
en réalité d'embastiller d'emprisonner
des gens sur la base de simples soupçons
je m'explique il existe un délit qui est
récent qui s'appelle la préparation à
une association de malfaiteurs en vue de
commettre des actes terroristes
qu'est ce que c'est ce délit vous
consulté quelques sites internet vous
échangez avec un copain embrigader comme
vous sur le thème on va commettre des
attentats éventuellement vous faites 3
recherche de plus vous poser une option
sur un billet pour aller chez pas où
vous êtes dans le daily préparation à
une association de malfaiteurs vous
encourez 10 ans prison et les gens sur
la base de sa sont effectivement
incarcéré donc c'est faux de dire qu'on
n'a pas les outils aujourd'hui légaux
législatif pour répondre à cette menace
et il est faux aussi de penser est fou à
mon avis de penser que seulement avec la
loi on va lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme la citation de boris johnson
quand les lois ne sont plus efficaces il
faut changer les lois à la aucun sens
il ya de la pauvreté on va pas faire une
loi qui dit à partir de maintenant il
n'y a plus de pauvreté et on aura réglé
pour être de la pauvreté on nous a bien
évidemment d'autres heures d'autres
causes et enfin pour terminer
moi je suis toujours très inquiète quand
on justifie tout lé durcissement du
système par l'existence d'une menace
terroriste
je prends un exemple très récent qui va
vous parler la france va être le premier
pays d'europe à tester la reconnaissance
faciale l'allemagne allait mettre en
place le système
finalement il ya une bronca à
l'intérieur du système politique et
parmi les juristes allemands qui ont dit
non ça quand même on va trop loin nous
on n'y va pas ils ont renoncé au projet
nous on y va tout le monde s'en fiche
complètement
on en a discuté bon d'accord mais si
mais si non franchement je n'ai pas
observé que ça suscitait un débat donc
on va se retrouver encore plus fliquer
qu'avant avec toutes les caméras qu'il
ya sur le territoire français avec la
reconnaissance faciale
en gros on sera plus surveillé que
jamais mais en fait tout ça on le fait
pourquoi pour dire oui mais quand tu y
as
un quelqu'un qui commet un attentat ou
même quand il ya des gens qui commettent
des infractions etc
il faut bien pouvoir les réprimer donc
on finit par accepter de vivre dans une
société complètement surveillée où on
peut plus faire un pas de côté
tout ça parce que on essaye de se
défendre contre le terrorisme
moi je trouve ça extrêmement dangereux
et je pense franchement que les français
méritent mieux que d'être surveillés
matin midi et soir par leur ministre de
l'intérieur leur police leur
gouvernement évidemment que tout le
monde est contre le flicage généralisé
et le fichage généralisé et la
reconnaissance faciale dans la rue parce
que cs c'est quoi mais le fichage
généralisé pardonnez-moi mais sauf que
appliquer cette belle théorie à la halle
à la réponse qui doit le pénal qui doit
être donné ce qui est ce que font les
gens comme vous qui défendre l'état de
droit comme un mantra comme si c'était
quelque chose qui n'avait jamais bougé
et elle et des tables de la loi de
l'ariège est menacée qui n'existe pas
dans tous les pays du monde qui existe
dans une minorité de payer 2 certes mais
c'est pas des tables de la loi non plus
être faite au nom de l'êta de bras
aujourd'hui on change plus le droit ça
que j'en retiens de vous dire au
lendemain des attentats vous avez des
politiques qui monte à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale en l'occurrence je
pense à manuel valls après l'attentât de
nice et qui disent surtout on ne sortira
jamais de l'état bois on ne change rien
on change rien pourquoi au nom de quoi
mais il faut arrêter de faire des lois
tout manuel valls dray ils n'ont pas
arrêté de faire des lois qui ont durci
le système cake qu'est ce que vous
voulez c'est moi c'est ça qui me kim qui
me fascine c'est que on se demande
jusqu'où est ce qu'il faut aller pour
donner satisfaction à ceux qui un peu
comme les néons coller aux
néoconservateurs américains demandent
d'aller toujours plus loin
vous trouvez que guantanamo c est là
c'est à l'honneur des états unis vous
trouvez que c'est leur honneur d'avoir
fait ça vous voulez qu'on fasse la même
chose de vraiment n'incarcère des gens
sans qu'ils passent devant un juge sans
qu'il y ait une enquête sans qu'ils
aient pu se défendre
non moi je suis désolé je ne suis pas
d'accord avec moi je suis pour je rêve
d'une formule qui a été une très bonne
formule mais qui n'a jamais été respecté
et appliqué en tout cas c'est qu'on
fasse comme disait pasqua qui ont
terrorisé les terroristes je constate
qu'aujourd'hui alors c'est très
intéressant parce que vous savez aussi
ce qu'il a dit une fois oui après une
prise d'otage a dit forcé rester à la
loi
le forcené a été abattu et bien pour moi
c'est une très drôle de conception de
l'état de droit
il se l'est dit
les terroristes n'ont pas gagné en
france enfin ils gagneront aussi demain
on n'a plus aucune liberté mais ils
n'ont pas gagné la france et
conquise par les terroristes
ils ont tous été arrêtés ou supprimés
ils ont fait quasiment 300 morts en
trois ans ont déjoué des attentats
régulièrement il ya quand même une armée
secrète qui qui qui travaille
aujourd'hui à attaquer la france avec
cette méthode le terrorisme et qui est
une méthode qui ne vise pas la vue la
vie de la conquête militaire ou la
conquête territoriale mais le fait est
anisé tout le monde et je crois que ça
fonctionne bien mais bon j'ai parlé avec
les gens ils vont ne vont pas dans les
cafés ne vont pas dans les salles de
spectacle ne vont pas au cinéma ne se
rassemblent pas sur la place publique
non mais d'accord j'ai dire juste après
les attentats il ya eu des marches les
fameuses marches de janvier où tout le
monde était descendu dans la rue alors
que la menace est imminente la menace
terrorisme ça a pas empêché les gens des
gambiens vous pouvoir le panorama tout
entier moi j'habite pas très loin d'une
synagogue il ya eu des policiers pendant
deux ans aujourd'hui et des policiers à
côté des écoles et même après les
policiers partis avec mes mais y avait
péno mais c'est une réalité il ya des
policiers partout quand il ya des
rassemblements je pense à la coupe du
monde notamment il ya aussi des
policiers partout on est sous la menace
permanente ce que les gens aux gens leur
moi je pense pas que les gens pensent je
pense que frédéric taddeï a raison les
les les terroristes n'ont pas réussi
leur n'ont pas atteint leur objectif
c'est pas vrai c'est bien mais c'est pas
vrai que qu'ils atteignent leur objectif
est donc et on peut considérer qu'ils
ont perdus et que la démocratie c'est à
dire justement l'état de droit la
liberté
le fait de dire on va pas changer nos
modes de vie parce que ces gens ont
envie qu'on change le mode de vie a
gagné contre l'environnement une
dernière question parce que je n'aurais
eu plein d'autres mais on n'aura pas le
temps mais qui essuient la précédente
faut-il continuer d'intervenir
militairement en afrique au moyen-orient
dans des conflits interminables qui nous
valent beaucoup de style it est pas mal
d'ennemis et que l'on ne gagne jamais
vraiment enfin moi je me sois mal mal
renseignés ou
ou ne faut-il employer la violence je
parle militaire que lorsque l'on est
attaquée directement c'est moi qui
commence à écouter pour parler de ce
qu'on connaît actuellement à savoir le
mali
moi je ne critique pas l'intervention
française au mali pour pour deux raisons
d déjà d'un point de vue malien dans un
truc guillemets parce que en tout cas
par rapport à ce qui se passe là bas je
pense qu'on combat là bas un ennemi qui
serait chez nous sinon donc ça a été
l'argument utilisé notamment par macron
pour justifier a très peu de temps
l'intervention française là bas mais
même françois hollande ne l'avait
utilisée aussi je pense qu en aidant le
mali à ne pas se faire dévorer par le
djihadisme combat un peu le djihadisme
chez nous ça c'est la première chose et
puis d'un point de vue plus français et
par rapport à nos intérêts je considère
et le charles parlé tout à l'heure de
notre capacité de projection militaire
et du fait qu'on est la seule puissance
européenne à être capable de se projeter
longtemps dans un théâtre d'opérations
extérieures
ce que par exemple l'allemagne ne peut
pas faire nous donne une influence
considérable sur le plan diplomatique
les et par rapport à d'autres grandes
puissances même si on peut pas comparer
notre budget militaire avec celui par
exemple des états unis mais en revanche
on peut se comparer à d'autres et ne pas
rougir
donc je considère si vous voulez que la
france est grande aussi de cette
puissance est notamment quand elle ne
l'utilisent pas à dire qu'on a tous en
tête 2003 il ya des moments aussi il
faut dire qu'on n'y va pas et il faut
expliquer pourquoi et jacques chirac à
la je vous rappelle que du temps du
général de gaulle où nous étions une
puissance indépendante et nous avions
même quitté le commandement intégré de
l'otan
il y avait cette puissance nous avions
la bombe atomique mais on ne serait
jamais allé combattre dèche en irak
qu'enfin semble-t-il c'est je peux me
tromper les vrais de se mettre à la
place général de gaulle mais on aurait
dire il n'y a pas eu de cas où la france
s'est aligné comme ça sur une coalition
internationale
vous avez raison mais l'alignement c'est
différent de 2
de décider de se projeter cerqueux au
mali on c'est nous qui sommes la malice
et autres vêtements évidemment moi je
suis je suis très fier quand la france
refuse de suivre une opération
américaine pour des intérêts américains
et je considère qu'en effet c'est il
faut exercer cette puissance y compris
en ne conservant pas par moments ça ne
la tue je suis parfait mais le mali
nouveau beaucoup d'hostilité en afrique
comme notre présence militaire en
centrafrique au tchad où l'on s'allier
avec des dictateurs enfin tout ça n'est
pas simple là aussi les français sont à
la fois partagé j'ai l'impression que la
droite elle-même est partagé charles
continue parce que comme vous dites
c'est très compliqué donc c'est
difficile d'avoir une position
complètement univoque sur le sur la
question il ya plusieurs choses d'abord
la france a quand même une voix
singulière qui a toujours été d'être
tournés vers les plus faibles à
l'échelle du monde
elle a toujours été ce pays qui parmi
les pays riches tendait la main aux pays
pauvres aux pays les plus faibles ça a
été particulièrement vrai sous la
présidence de jacques chirac
mais je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est resté et tendre la main c'est bien
mais à les aider sur place c'est bien
aussi
on parlait à l'instant de l'état de
droit je disais qu'il est minoritaire
dans le dans le monde c'est vrai il ya
un nombre de pays majoritaires qui
vivent sous des régimes qui sont pas des
régimes démocratiques et qui donc
subissent le quotidien de ce que c'est
que d'être soumis à l'arbitraire et donc
dans ces cas là quand ya une opportunité
je pense par exemple on a beaucoup
critiqué sarkozy d'être intervenu en
libye
mais moi je suis désolé je pense que la
france si après elle a été lamentable de
ne pas gérer les suites de cette
intervention en réalité elle avait tout
à fait raison d'intervenir en libye est
d'empêcher kadhafi de dégorger ses
propres citoyens
donc je me serais sur une ligne assez
interventionniste moi j'adhère je
déplore le fait que la ligne
souverainiste là dessus la ligne et
moore et finit par gagner
le combat des idées sur cette question
cette année à droite vous pensez à
droite à gauche partout aujourd'hui tout
le monde se range derrière cette idée
oui non s'en mêle pas ça se passe à
l'étranger ça nous regarde pas c'est
facile aussi de faire ça on a fait ça à
cause de barack obama en syrie françois
hollande était prêt à intervenir et
barack obama a finalement annulé
finalement renoncé à participer à cette
intervention est donc ça a empêché cette
intervention résultat on a eu une guerre
civile qui a fait plusieurs centaines de
milliers de morges pas si on est à 200
milles ou à 300 milles mais c'est quand
même sans précédent dans la période
récente donc peut-être qu'on aurait de
l'intérieur et je finis un point je
pense que ça fait quand même partie de
la puissance d'un pays que de pouvoir
intervenir à l'étranger et je prends un
autre exemple que l'intervention
militaire
moi j'ai été très chagriné de voir qu'on
n'était pas capable la france de sortir
carlos ghosn de sa prison japonaises
exportant des biens sur moi je suis
désolé mais droit japonais mais je suis
désolé on est oui mais on est une grande
puissance
on a un patron d'un de nos fleurons qui
est incarcéré à l'étranger un fleuron
dans lequel l'état français est
actionnaire
il est incarcéré à l'étranger dans des
conditions extrêmement trouble sur la
base d'une affaire dont on se demande si
c'est pas une affaire d' influence
japonaise sur notre industrie et on
n'est pas capable par la voie
diplomatique de le ramener en france
même on aurait pu accepter qu'il soit
quand même jugé au japon mais on n'est
pas capable et tu veux ramener sur le
territoire français liberté surveillée
en france tout ce que vous voulez on
n'est pas capable la léchère de le
sortir de sa prison
je suis désolé il y avait un américain
qui était mis en cause dans la même
affaire
il est resté 15 jours en détention
provisoire donald trump a tapé du poing
sur la table il est retourné aux états
unis donc moi ça me chagrine parce que
ce canton c'est plus sortir un français
détenus à l'étranger de sa prison ça
veut dire qu'on est faible florence k 16
on s'est battu pour qu'elle sorte on
n'était pas sûr qu'elle soit exaucé en
collège sarkozy c'était ça paye et on
s'est battu pour qu'elle sorte
elle est revenue madame
bettencourt j'oublie son son prénom
j'allais l'appeler liliane bettencourt
mais c'est pas ça comment elle
s'appelait déjà visionné une grille de
béthencourt pardon on l'a alors certes
c'était un groupe armé qui la détenaient
mais il n'empêche que la france s'est
battue et penser à l'oral est normal
avant l'averse de geoffroy qu'il fallait
aussi se battre pour ramener les
jihadistes français leurs femmes et
leurs enfants qui sont actés se battent
se battre je ne sais pas les enfants oui
il me semble que des enfants français
des enfants de nationalité française ne
sont pas responsable du fait que leurs
parents fous aveugle et cruelle les ont
amenés en irak en pleine terre
djihadistes donc les enfants oui je
crois qu'il faut les rats dernier mot je
fois il reste une minute sur cette
question bat la différence est que les
enfants de jay dix personnes ne les
retenaient en syrie il vous avait plutôt
envie de rentrer et tout le monde
voulait qu'ils rentrent non notre point
d accord sur ce sujet là c'est ça va
être moi je pense que la frontière c'est
le néo colonialisme français qui
considèrent que c'est à nous de régler
tous les problèmes dans les pays
notamment au proche orient au
moyen-orient percée dans le cas de la
libye mais je me souviens en plus très
bien du contexte à l'époque dans lequel
on était intervenu ça participé d'un
moment juste après les printemps arabes
où il fallait absolument si on voulait
prouver sa puissance renverser tous les
semis dictateur qui était en place pour
tout à coup la liberté des peuples etc
on se rend compte que cela conduisait
tout à coup à l'élection je dis bien
l'élection parce que quand il ya eu des
élections de d'islamistes qui tout à
coup et est beaucoup moins nos amis que
les dictateurs entre guillemets laïque
donc moi dans ce contexte là j'étais
complètement sur la ligne pas
d'intervention etc
mais je vous disais la puissance parfois
ça ne s'exerce pas mais elle existe
quand même merci tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission à débat qui
ne finit qui n'est pas finie qui
continuera pour la droite
en tout cas merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]